which of the following functions are a
continuous
for all real numbers so let's just
remind ourselves what it means to be
continuous what a continuous function
looks like
so a continuous function let's say
that's my y-axis
that is my x-axis a function is going to
be continuous over some interval if it
doesn't have any
jumps or discontinuities over that or
gaps over that interval so if if it's
connected or and it for sure has to be
defined over that interval without any
gaps so for example an example a
continuous function could look something
like
this
this function let me make that line a
little bit thicker
so this function right over here is
continuous it is connected over this
interval the interval that we can see
now examples of discontinuous functions
over an interval or non-continuous
functions well they would have gaps of
some kind they could have some type of
an asymptotic discontinuity so something
like that
that makes it discontinuous they could
have
a jump discontinuity something like
that they could just have a gap where
they're where they're not defined
so they could have a gap where they're
not defined or maybe it's maybe they
actually are defined there but it's
removable discontinuity so all of these
are examples of discontinuous functions
now if you want the more mathy
understanding of that and we've looked
at this before we say that a function f
is continuous
continuous at some
value x equals a if and only if draw my
little two-way arrows here say if and
only if the limit
of f of x
as x approaches a is equal to the value
of the function at a so once again in
order to be continuous there you at
least have to be defined there
now when you look at these the one thing
that jumps out at me in order to be
continuous for all real numbers you have
to be defined for all real numbers and g
of x is not defined for all real numbers
it's not defined for negative values of
x
and so
we would
rule this one out
so let's think about f of x equals e to
the x
it is defined for all real numbers
and as we'll see
most of the common functions that you've
learned in math they don't have these
strange jumps or gaps or discontinuities
some of them do
functions like one over x and
and things like that but things like e
to the x it doesn't have any of those we
could graph e to the x e to the x looks
something like
e to the x looks something like this
it's defined for all real numbers
there's no jumps or gaps of any kind and
so
this e f of x is continuous for all real
numbers and f only now i didn't do a
very rigorous proof you could if you
like but for the sake of this exercise
it's really more of getting this
intuitive sense of like look look e to
the x is defined for all real numbers
and
so
and there's no jumps or gaps here so
it's reasonable say that it's continuous
but you could do a more rigorous proof
if you like as well